[Musica]
laddove c'è il pericolo cresce anche ciò
che salva queste parole del grande poeta
tedesco federline sono state spesso
riprese dai filosofi del novecento per
descrivere per descrivere il significato
della tecnica ossia dello sviluppo
tecnico scientifico lo anni fa ho
progettato presso l'università di udine
il primo master in italia in filosofia
del digitale menziono questo aspetto
della mia vita professionale perché a
partire da questa prospettiva filosofica
che intendo affrontare il tema di oggi
ossia il rapporto tra il digitale la
democrazia e la globalizzazione il
digitale e la globalizzazione ci offrono
grandi opportunità ma anche diverse
questioni su cui riflettere per la prima
volta nella storia dell'umanità
ci troviamo ad affrontare concretamente
il problema di come realizzare forme di
democrazia sovranazionale
ma guardiamo innanzitutto lo stato di
salute della democrazia nel mondo sono
circa 36 le guerre attualmente in atto e
sono circa 65 i paese coinvolte su 167
stati esaminati sono solo 23 gli stati a
democrazia completa 52 sono le
democrazie imperfette 35 i regimi ibridi
e 57 i regimi autoritari
l'indice democratico e democracy index
2020 2021 posiziona l'italia al
ventinovesimo posto
questi dati ci offrono una prima
fotografia del mondo di oggi
alcuni anni fa ho definito l'attuale
crisi una crisi politica strutturale
perché mentre la politica agisce
localmente all'interno di specifiche
scale territoriali per esempio città
regioni stati nazione l'economia e la
finanza operano invece su scala globale
e trans nazionale alcuni numeri e alcuni
esempi ci possono aiutare a capire
perché ci troviamo all'interno
una crisi politica strutturale
oggi abbiamo multinazionali che sono più
ricchi e più potenti di interi stati
nazione
la globalizzazione sta dando vita a veri
e propri monopoli
perché la politica non riesce a
governare questi soggetti economico
finanziari nelle mani di pochi
si stanno concentrando ingenti quantità
di denaro ed interessi 85 persone nel
mondo possiedono una ricchezza pari a
quella di 3 miliardi e mezzo di
individui i dieci italiani più ricchi
possiedono un patrimonio pari e
corrispondente a 3 milioni di poveri ma
vediamo il dato forse più significativo
la somma del pil di tutti i paesi del
mondo si aggira attorno a 54 mila
miliardi di dollari mentre il totale dei
capitali speculativi che passano da una
piazza finanziaria un'altra si aggira
attorno a 5 540 mila miliardi di dollari
ossia è dieci volte superiore
allora perché i cittadini si allontanano
dalla politica
quando la politica i partiti non
rappresentano ne tutelano gli interessi
legittimi delle persone i cittadini
chiaramente si allontanano dalla
politica e ciò non dipende dalla
capacità o dall incapacità del singolo
politico come dicevo prima la crisi è
strutturale
siamo dinanzi a un affermazione del
piano economico su quello politico
vi ricordate lo slogan noi siamo il 99
per cento
e allora perché l'un per cento decide
sul restante 99 per cento ce lo dicono i
numeri perché quell un per cento è molto
potente come abbiamo visto prima
per esempio l'un per cento più ricco
sotto il profilo patrimoniale deteneva a
metà del 2019 più del doppio della
ricchezza netta posseduta da 6,9
miliardi di persone
si impone così alla nostra attenzione
un enorme problema di equità e di
giustizia sociale
tutti oggi almeno a parole si dicono
democratici ma il problema non è
definirsi democratici il problema è
quale idea di democrazia abbiamo in
mente questo il punto fondamentale la
globalizzazione comporta un problema di
rappresentanza e quindi un problema di
democrazia ossia dobbiamo rispondere
alla domanda chi decide i pochi o in
molti allora ci troviamo di fronte a due
problemi uno è un deficit di
rappresentanza e l'altro è un problema
di governance globale che fare
denunciare i problemi è relativamente
facile individuare delle soluzioni è
complicato nemmeno io le soluzioni
nessuno oggi alle soluzioni
tuttavia alcuni anni fa ho provato a
definire alcune idee guida su cui
provare a riflettere ea lavorare stati
uniti del mondo e democrazia diretta e
digitale la prima idea guida cioè stati
uniti del mondo vuole e intende
rispondere al problema della governance
la seconda idea guida democrazia diretta
digitale invece intende rispondere al
problema della rappresentanza
si tratta appunto di idee guida di idee
regolative possono sembrare affermazioni
forse troppo astratta e troppo
filosofiche ma se non stabiliamo dove
vogliamo andare
come possiamo definire la rotta ci
troveremmo come una nave in balia delle
onde priva di una meta per poter
stabilire cosa fare oggi ci servono dei
criteri e una meta e quindi delle idee
guida queste due idee guida sono due
facce della stessa medaglia
vediamo innanzitutto dapprima idea guida
stati uniti del mondo dobbiamo
risvegliare una cultura cosmopolita
dobbiamo riscoprire un orizzonte
politico più ampio dello stato nazione
stati uniti del mondo o meglio città
unite nel mondo sono paradossalmente un
punto di partenza è un punto di arrivo
oggi infatti le nostre città sono già
collegate tra loro continuamente noi
scambiamo informazioni e in questo senso
sono un punto di partenza e
congiuntamente rappresentano anche un
punto verso cui tendere
il principio è che problemi economici di
natura globale devono trovare delle
soluzioni politiche di natura globale
si tratta di un discorso questo troppo
astratto utopico ma senza questa
prospettiva tutti i grandi problemi che
affliggono il nostro tempo quali la fame
nel mondo
le guerre il clima l'ambiente la
sovrapopolazione non possono trovare
soluzione cioè non possono incontrare
soluzioni concrete a livello locale
per questo serve una prospettiva globale
non auspico con questo è un supergoverno
del mondo ma forme di governance globale
di sì
l'europa l'europa in tal senso potrebbe
giocare ancora un ruolo decisivo non
tanto o non solo da un punto di vista
economico anche se in fondo d'europa
rappresenta oggi circa il 21 per cento
del mercato globale e il 22 per cento
del pil mondiale ma innanzitutto in
termini valoriali
in questi termini l'europa non
corrisponderebbe più a un luogo
geografico un paese per esempio potrebbe
stare geograficamente al centro
dell'europa e non essere europeo così
come un altro paese potrebbe trovarsi
geograficamente lontano dall'europa ed
essere europeo
penso a un unione europea di tipo
politico fatta prima di tutto su valori
e non meramente sostanze economico
finanziaria
la globalizzazione richiede una risposta
dall alto e una dal basso
abbiamo considerato alcune possibili
azioni dall'alto
ora vediamo che cosa possiamo fare dal
basso attraverso la seconda idea guida
quella della democrazia diretta e
digitale si tratta di valorizzare
l'autonomia dei territori
di rilanciare la cultura federalista le
piccole realtà
e perché perché la globalizzazione
indebolisce irrimediabilmente il tessuto
economico locale territoriale
a oggi infatti si tende a delocalizzare
la produzione ea delegare i servizi
perché semplicemente perché è
conveniente farlo oggi almeno è
conveniente farlo ma in prospettiva sarà
ancora conveniente quando il sistema con
la sera questa è una facile profezia
dato che tutto prima o poi viene meno
cosa resterà all'interno dei nostri
territori
poco o nulla perché nel frattempo avremo
delocalizzato e delegato i servizi alle
grandi piattaforme internazionali
per questo dobbiamo rafforzare le
autonomie territoriali rendendole in
prospettiva sempre più autonome questa
autonomia può essere ottenuta attraverso
la promozione di economie circolari e
attraverso lo sviluppo dell'energia
rinnovabile
tutte queste prospettive implicano nuova
ricerca e nuova conoscenza
il legame tra economia impresa e
università e quindi territorio è
fondamentale
l'università può giocare in tal senso un
doppio ruolo locale e globale
la conoscenza infatti è per sua natura
globale ma la sua applicazione e anche
locale e territoriale
se pensata in funzione dell'economia e
del territorio e rispetto alle imprese
agli interessi del territorio
in tal senso servono le prospettive
ecologica cioè dobbiamo rendere il
nostro sviluppo sostenibile
ma che cosa c'entra tutto questo
discorso con la democrazia digitale la
democrazia digitale va inserita e
pensata all'interno di questo quadro
concettuale di riferimento ecologia
digitale sono strettamente legate anzi
inscindibili la democrazia digitale non
va pensata singolarmente in modo
autonomo ma inserita all'interno di
questo contesto di questo quadro
fallimento concettuale il vantaggio
della democrazia digitale e che può
essere applicata gradualmente e non va
intesa in alcun modo in opposizione alle
forme di democrazia rappresentativa
il principio è che la democrazia
digitale va applicata dove possibile e
tutte le volte che è possibile anche
all'interno delle nostre metropoli ma a
partire dalle piccole realtà ossia dai
quartieri dai singoli quartieri
dobbiamo partire dalle piccole realtà
perché è più facile sperimentare sulla
piccola scala e vedere cosa funziona e
cosa non funziona accogliere ciò che
funziona e respinge con un metodo
sperimentale ciò che non funziona quindi
senza alcun approccio di tipo ideologico
possiamo sperimentare nuove forme di
partecipazione democratica attraverso la
democrazia digitale ma ribadisco
partendo dal basso partendo dalla
piccola scala così forse possiamo anche
riavvicinare i cittadini alla politica
per recuperare il punto su cui ci siamo
soffermati prima dando loro un peso
concreto e reale e facendoli prima di
tutto decidere appunto facendoli decide
e partecipare partecipare e decidere
ribadisco ancora una volta che tale
prospettiva non è in alcun modo posta o
pensata in contrapposizione o in
opposizione alla democrazia
rappresentativa
la democrazia per definizione non è
qualcosa di stabile di immobile ma deve
evolvere per non involvere ed è un bene
che come la salute che accorge del suo
valore
solo quando lo stai perdendo abbiamo
visto attraverso queste due idee guida
possibili azioni dall'alto e dal basso
si tratta di idee nuove ma fino a un
certo punto
in verità la prima idea risale almeno a
kant la prospettiva cosmopolita che poi
abbiamo articolato è sviluppato
attraverso l'idea degli stati uniti nel
mondo
la seconda idea di sale a russo
razzia di alette naturalmente non quella
digitale ma ancora una volta possono
siamo partiti dalla verità l'idea di
democrazia diretta per poi sviluppare
l'idea della democrazia digitale
allora che cosa rende queste idee
attuali oltre che attuabili la
tecnologia lo sviluppo tecnologico
possiamo allora recuperare le parole
iniziali del poeta feder di là dove c'è
il pericolo la globalizzazione laddove
c'è il pericolo il digitale possiamo
trovare anche ciò che salva
questa la sfida che ci attende